[Music]
who did punishments in Islamic law are
those that are considered to be fixed by
Allah himself in the Quran and Sunnah as
such they cannot be relaxed or mitigated
without in the eyes of many sinning
against Allah most who did punishments
are specified in the Quran itself for
example amputation of the hand for theft
as to the thief the Quran says male or
female cut off his or her hands a
punishment by way of example from Allah
for their crime and the LA is exalted in
power crucifixion is actually specified
in the Quran as well as amputation or
exile for those who were considered to
be Waging War against Allah and Muhammad
now you think about that that's a very
elastic concept Waging War against Allah
in Muhammad the punishment it says of
those to wage war against Allah and his
messenger and strive with might and man
for Mischief through the land is
execution or crucifixion or the cutting
off of hands and feet from opposite
sides or Exile from the land that is
their disgrace in this world and a heavy
punishment is theirs in the
Hereafter lashing for elicit sex is also
set out in the Quran the Quran says the
man and the woman guilty of adultery or
fornication flog each of them with 100
Stripes let not compassion move you in
their casee in a matter prescribed by
Allah if you believe in Allah in the
last day and let a party of the
Believers witness their punishment now
let not compassion move you in their
case is already departing from any idea
of God as genuinely merciful and
compassionate but it gets even worse in
a Hadith where the kff Umar one of
Muhammad's closest companions said that
the penalty for adultery was not lashing
at all but was actually stoning to death
and even maintained that that was what
was originally
in the Quran although he doesn't explain
how it dropped out according to a Hadith
Umar said I am afraid that after a long
time has pass people may say we do not
find the verses of the rajim stoning to
death in the holy book and consequently
they may go astray by leaving an
obligation that Allah has revealed and
so Umar adds lo I confirm that the
penalty of rajim be inflicted on him who
commits illegal sexual intercourse if he
is already married and the crime is
proved by Witnesses or pregnancy or
confession the Hadith goes on to say
that another one of Muhammad's followers
sufan added I have memorized this
narration in this way in other words
it's another authoritative witness Umar
added surely Allah's Apostle carried out
the penalty of rajim and so did we after
him because of course in Islam Muhammad
is the excellent example of conduct the
crime of false accusation of adultery or
rape is also to be punished with 80
lashes as per the Quran and those who
accuse ch Chast women and then do not
produce four Witnesses lash them with 80
lashes and do not accept from them
testimony Ever After and those are the
defiantly disobedient drinking alcohol
is also to be punished with 80 lashes
that comes from a Hadith Anis IB Malik
reported that a person who had drunk
wine was brought to Allah's apostle that
is Muhammad he gave him 40 stripes with
two lashes Abu Bakr also did that but
when Umar assumed the responsibilities
of the caliphate he consulted people and
abdar another follower of Muhammad said
the mildest punishment for drinking is
80 lashes and Umar thus prescribed this
punishment another Hadith has Muhammad
himself saying if he's intoxicated flog
him if he's intoxicated again flog him
again if he's intoxicated a third time
flog him and if he does it again a
fourth time kill
him these punishments are not considered
to be open to mitigation as they are
commanded by Allah or Muhammad and the
Quran repeatedly tells Muslims to obey
Allah and his messenger and so to this
day wherever Sharia law is fully inforce
these punishments are enforced upon the
populace creating an Empire of fear
which is what Sharia actually is